This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。嘿，大家近来可好？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）为你带来的《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的真实经历，进行那些在别处实在不安全、无法畅所欲言的深度对话。但在这里，你将与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人一直穿着一副盔甲？这向世界发出了一个信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就非得把它用出来。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
欢迎在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《以艰难的方式学习》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这需要动用一大批互联网侦探，才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格，一名女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我当时震惊得无以复加。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his
这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。收听《2%》。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟是同一个多产的世纪骗子时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。这将是他的
last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, you know the deal, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s.
最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信女朋友，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时所经历的重大生活变化与转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎再次回到节目中。欢迎收听本期播客。新听众、老听众，你们都懂的，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，陪伴我们开启另一期节目，深入剖析二十岁的心理学。
I'm really excited for this episode. I think that the emotion we're speaking about today is one that we don't talk about enough. And what I really want to explore is the psychology behind guilt, particularly chronic guilt or feelings of guilt for things that we haven't done or holding, carrying an emotional burden that we don't deserve to. It is such a common experience, I think, particularly amongst people in this generation, to feel this lingering feeling that we have done something wrong, even when there's no evidence for it, or that someone is secretly mad at you, that you are a monster. Here is a spoiler. You are not a monster. You have just been conditioned into believing that you are responsible for other people's emotions. This is a concept known as the
我真的非常期待这一期节目。我认为我们今天所讨论的情感，是我们平时谈论得还不够多的情感。我真正想要探究的是内疚背后的心理机制，特别是长期内疚，或者为那些我们根本没有做过的事情感到内疚，又或者背负着、承载着我们本不该承受的情感负担。这是一种非常普遍的体验，我认为，尤其是在我们这一代人当中，会有一种挥之不去的错觉，觉得自己做错了什么，哪怕根本没有任何证据；或者觉得别人在暗中生你的气，觉得你是个怪物。这里有个剧透。你不是怪物。你只是被环境塑造成了这样，让你误以为自己应该为别人的情绪负责。这是一个被称为
guilt complex, intense and frequent feelings of guilt that aren't associated or connected to any event in particular. Guilt is so interesting to me because it's such an intricate emotion and a lot of psychologists still don't really understand it that well. We don't really know where it comes from, why it occurs. Obviously there is this very traditional idea of guilt, this very severe sense of guilt that is associated with committing a crime or doing something horrific or something that you deeply regret. And of course, this kind of guilt does exist, this sense of blame for the harm that you've caused others, but I don't really think it's the kind of guilt that most of us in our 20s are actually experiencing. This kind of guilt,
内疚情结（guilt complex）的概念，即产生与任何具体事件都没有关联的、强烈而频繁的内疚感。内疚对我而言非常有趣，因为它是一种极其复杂的情感，许多心理学家至今仍未能真正透彻地理解它。我们其实并不知道它从何而来，又为何会产生。显然，有一种非常传统的内疚观念，即那种与犯罪、做可怕的事或深感后悔的事情紧密相连的、极其严重的内疚感。当然，这种内疚确实存在，这种因自己给他人造成的伤害而产生的自责感，但我并不认为这是我们大多数二十岁年轻人真正经历的那种内疚。这种内疚，
where we commit a crime, we do something bad. It's called reactive guilt. But we can also just have guilty thoughts, which we never intend to act on, but they kind of sit in our brain and fester and convince us that we are evil. We also just feel a real general guilt about the injustices in the world, extraditional guilt, because we feel responsible for other people's suffering. But I think the kind of guilt that we mostly experience is guilt towards things we haven't done or are yet to do. Guilt around upsetting people or displaced guilt, feeling that sense of shame or accountability for another person's emotions or for choosing to behave in a way that is completely justified, but might upset other people. This has become a lot more common and I think relatable
也就是我们犯罪了，或者做了坏事。这被称为反应性内疚（reactive guilt）。但我们也会产生一些内疚的想法，虽然我们从来没打算付诸行动，但它们却在我们的脑海里盘旋、溃烂，让我们确信自己是个恶人。我们也会对世界上的不公正现象产生一种普遍的内疚感，这是一种超常规的内疚（extraditional guilt），因为我们觉得自己要为他人的苦难负责。但我认为我们经历最多的内疚，是对那些我们没有做过或尚未做过的事情产生的内疚。围绕着惹恼别人产生的内疚，或是被转移的内疚（displaced guilt），即为别人的情绪、或为选择做出完全正当但可能惹恼别人的行为，而感到的一种羞耻感或责任感。这变得越来越普遍，而且我认为
for people in their 20s, especially because there's this very deep philosophy around not only just being a good person, but also treating this decade with a certain, like, distinctiveness, a certain romance. And that places a lot of pressure, a lot of expectations on us. And not just straightforward expectations about living up to your parents' dreams for you or taking advantage of opportunities or being successful, but also these expectations to be doing the most, to be living a fantasy life, to make everybody happy, to constantly be happy yourself. For a lot of us, that is not the case. And I think we often feel guilty that perhaps we are wasting what some would call the best years of our lives, or that we are passing up privileges that other people would die for. We feel guilty for choosing
对于二十多岁的人来说也更能感同身受，尤其是因为这里存在着一种根深蒂固的哲学：不仅要做一个好人，还要带着某种特定的、独特的、带有浪漫色彩的方式来对待这个十年。这就给我们带来了很大的压力和期望。这些期望不仅是直截了当地要达到父母对你的期望、抓住机遇或获得成功，还包括那些要做最多事情、过上幻想般的生活、让每个人都开心、让自己时刻保持快乐的期望。对我们许多人来说，事实并非如此。我认为我们常常会感到内疚，或许是因为觉得自己正在浪费别人口中“人生中最美好的几年”，又或是因为我们拒绝了一些别人做梦都想得到的特权。我们为选择
to rest, then we feel guilty for choosing to go out. We feel guilty for spending too much time at work, but also guilty when we're not working, guilty for choosing to prioritize ourselves, guilty for making mistakes. That is just one facet, but another common aspect has to do with our relationships and our friendships. Friendships, I have this belief, are the most important relationship that we have in our 20s. You know, some of us find partners, a lot of us are still connected to our family, but the real lifeblood of our 20s, the real people who hold us up, who keep us feeling connected, are our friends. And with that sense of connection, comes a sense of expectation of not wanting to let them down. We feel like we need to be more
休息而感到内疚，接着又为选择出门而感到内疚。我们在工作中花费了太多时间而感到内疚，但不在工作时又会感到内疚；为了优先考虑自己而感到内疚，为犯错误而感到内疚。这只是其中一个方面，另一个常见的方面与我们的恋爱关系和友情有关。我相信，友情是我们二十多岁时最重要的人际关系。你知道的，我们中的一些人找到了伴侣，我们中的许多人依然与家庭保持着联系，但我们二十多岁的真正生命线，真正支撑着我们、让我们感到与世界保持联系的，是我们的朋友。伴随着这种连接感而来的，是一种期望感，是不想让他们失望。我们觉得我们需要变得更
available. We often encounter a fear of missing out, but deeper than that, a fear of disappointing people, especially as we slowly become adults and are trying to figure out who we are as individuals, trying to find more time for ourselves, working more, investing in our careers, and also trying to maintain those relationships, trying to be a good friend. And I think it's in those moments where we experience this intense sense of obligation to other people. We cannot always be what others expect us to be. Sometimes we do the wrong thing because we are still learning, because we are still kind of like we are baby adults.
容易被找到。我们经常会遇到害怕错过（FOMO）的心态，但比这更深层的，是害怕让人失望，尤其是当我们慢慢步入成年，试图弄清楚我们作为个体究竟是谁，试图为自己腾出更多时间，更多地投入到工作中、投资于我们的职业生涯，同时又试图维护这些关系、试图做一个好朋友的时候。我想，正是在这些时刻，我们对他人产生了强烈的责任感。我们不可能总是达到别人对我们的期望。有时我们会做错事，因为我们还在学习，因为我们某种程度上还像是一个个刚刚成年的婴儿。
And the emotional aftermath of not living up to a sense of expectation or obligation from others is this intense guilt, feeling like you are secretly a bad person. Essentially, guilt is that feeling that you aren't a good person. And that doesn't actually need to be the truth if you feel that way. and I've been thinking about this a lot of my own life recently because chronic guilt is a feeling I experience and I've spent a lot of time attempting to come to terms with. It's one of those kind of mental blocks that I'm constantly trying to work through. I'm trying to work through these dilemmas where I feel like a bad person for just prioritizing myself. You know, I feel a lot of guilt
未能达到他人的期望或责任感，其在情感上留下的后遗症就是这种强烈的内疚感，让你觉得自己私底下是个坏人。从本质上讲，内疚就是那种觉得自己不是个好人的感觉。而如果你有这种感觉，它其实并不一定就是事实。我最近在自己的生活中也一直在思考这个问题，因为长期内疚是我所经历的一种感觉，我花了很多时间试图去接受它。这是我一直在努力克服的那种心理障碍之一。我正努力去解决这些道德困境：仅仅因为优先考虑了自己，我就觉得自己是个坏人。你知道的，我为此感到了很多内疚
at not working as hard as I should or taking time off, even when I know I deserve it, because I feel like I need to work harder for my opportunities or that there is a certain standard or quantity of work that I need to do before resting. And then of course there's the guilt of not being a good friend for saying no to things, for canceling plans, for not being the same person than I was at 18 or 19 who wanted to go out all the time. Guilt that I've changed and that somehow I owe it to other people to stay the same. And part of my experience is with this emotion has been this underlying sense of blame or responsibility again for how others feel. And with that a persistent anxiety that someone out there is mad at me. Someone is holding a grudge. Someone is upset by something I've done unintentionally,
比如觉得自己工作不够努力，或者在明知自己应得的情况下请假休息，因为我觉得自己需要更努力地工作才能换来机会，或者在休息之前我必须完成一定标准或数量的工作。然后，当然还有因为对事物说“不”、取消计划、不再是那个18、19岁时总想外出社交的自己，而觉得自己不是个好朋友的内疚。我为自己已经改变而感到内疚，总觉得某种程度上我欠了别人一个保持不变的承诺。我对这种情感体验的一部分，其实根源于一种潜意识里的指责或责任感——依然是关于别人感觉如何的责任感。随之而来的便是一种持续的焦虑，担心外面的某个人正在生我的气。有人在记恨我。有人因为我无意中做过的事而感到不安，
whether it is forgetting to reply to a message or having plans when they ask me if I'm free. And it's highly senseless and irrational. And I think a part of our experience of guilt is also quite egotistical. I've been thinking about this a lot. But when we are experiencing misplaced chronic guilt, it's often because we are exaggerating the impact of our actions and choices. We kind of overestimate how much people really care, how much damage we're actually able to do. There are a myriad, several factors that come into this, including but not limited to perfectionism, people pleasing tendencies, the childhood guilt wound, anxiety, sensitivity to criticism. And then sometimes there are simply moments when you act in a way that betrays your
不管是忘记回复一条信息，还是在他们问我是否有空时我恰好有别的安排。这完全是毫无意义且不理性的。我认为我们对内疚的体验中，有一部分也带有相当高的利己主义色彩。我最近一直在思考这个问题。但是，当我们经历这种错位的长期内疚时，往往是因为我们夸大了自己的行为和选择所产生的影响。我们有点高估了别人到底有多在乎，高估了我们实际上能造成多大的破坏。有无数个因素共同导致了这一点，包括但不限于完美主义、取悦他人的倾向、童年内疚创伤、焦虑、对批评的敏感度。然后，有时也仅仅是因为你的某些行为背叛了你的
values. And that's something that we need to come to terms with. So we're going to explore all of that. We're going to explore the emotional experience of guilt, including how to kind of overcome moments where you feel responsible for something that has happened when it might not actually be your fault. So all of that and more, let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
价值观。这是我们需要坦然接受的事情。所以我们将探讨所有这些内容。我们将探索内疚的情感体验，包括如何克服那些在事情可能并非你的过错时，却觉得自己要承担责任的时刻。以上种种以及更多内容，让我们切入正题。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析心理坚韧、健身以及建立适应力的科学，在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
从而超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上所恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。收听《2%》。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“T-W-O-Percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）胸部的那一刻吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of course.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在播客《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客的节目，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的霹雳瘾（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为……
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
当然还有毒品。我不介意在白天谈论毒品，但为了让大家知道我的意思。我是说，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们讨论毒品的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把爱滋病（AIDS）摆在桌面上。谢谢你把那句话补充完整。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession
我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于这场追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到，我们其实已经拥有了
of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,
这样东西。而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·布恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
还是说你当个好人是因为你感到害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去当一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，让我们在我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》中，就治愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once.
打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《以艰难的方式学习》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之争，只为证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要动用一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格、那个女同性恋、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时震惊得无以复加。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice, is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县（Maricopa County）突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。
podcasts. So there's an important distinction that we need to make straight off the bat. Guilt can come from either doing something or not doing something and either from a perceived or an actual wrong. We are highly attuned to moments where we might have misbehaved or acted against the social norms. and that is because guilt is so core and critical and primal to how we as humans have kind of evolved and been socialized. Many psychologists suggest that guilt is primarily a social emotion.
所以，从一开始我们就需要做出一个重要的区分。内疚可以源于做了某事，也可以源于没有做某事；可以源于某种被认为的错误，也可以源于实际的错误。我们对那些自己可能行为不端或违背了社会规范的时刻高度敏感，这是因为内疚对于我们人类如何进化和被社会化而言，是如此核心、关键且原始。许多心理学家认为，内疚主要是一种社会情感。
It exists to tell us when we have acted in a way that is contrary to cultural norms and it comes from a realization that your actions affect others around you. It's really interesting because the ability to feel guilt, or at least responsibility, is actually one of the critical kind of stages or milestones in a child's emotional development, because it indicates that they are aware that their actions have consequences and that other people have their own emotional lives or feelings that we can alter an impact. That kind of goes to show how core it is to the human experience. It's also really fascinating because a lack of guilt is also very problematic from a clinical perspective. The inability to feel remorse is a huge indicator of an antisocial personality disorder of a lack of empathy.
它的存在是为了告诉我们，当我们的行为违背了文化规范时，它源于这样一种认识：你的行为会影响到你周围的人。这真的很有趣，因为感到内疚——或者至少是承担责任的能力——其实是儿童情感发展中的关键阶段或里程碑之一，因为它表明他们已经意识到自己的行为会产生后果，并且其他人也有他们自己的情感生活或感受，而我们能够去改变和影响这些感受。这在某种程度上说明了它对人类体验是多么核心。同样令人着迷的是，从临床角度来看，缺乏内疚感也是非常成问题的。无法感到悔恨是反社会人格障碍和缺乏同理心的巨大指标。
So whilst guilt might leave us feeling anxious, disappointed, undeserving, obsessing over the past, we could make an argument that without it you might be even in a worse place than you are now. The other thing I think is important to point out, kind of just doing a bullet point list of the general understanding of guilt right now, but it's important to point out that guilt and shame are also different. So guilt comes from doing something that you believe goes against your morals to harm another, whether you actually did harm that person or not. But shame, it doesn't necessarily mean that what you've done is wrong or immoral. It might not have necessarily hurt someone. it's more that you're going against how society believes you should be, you know, should be behaving.
因此，尽管内疚可能会让我们感到焦虑、失望、不配、沉溺于过去，但我们可以说，如果没有它，你的处境可能会比现在还要糟糕。我认为需要指出的另一件事，就是简单列个要点清单来概括目前对内疚的普遍理解——但指出内疚和羞耻（shame）是不同的也很重要。内疚源于做了某件事，而你认为这件事违背了你的道德去伤害了别人，无论你是否真的伤害了那个人。然而羞耻感并不一定意味着你做错了什么或不道德。它可能不一定会伤害到别人。它更多的是因为你违背了社会认为你应该成为的样子，你知道的，应该表现出来的样子。
You know, for example, you can feel shame about your weight or your sexual identity. It doesn't mean that it was wrong or that you deserve to feel that way, whereas guilt is more around knowing that what you did goes against something deeper about how society chooses to treat others, even if that wasn't actually the case. I want to turn to chronic guilt here because that is actually the main focus. of this episode and I've just gotten way too distracted. But there are some of us who are kind of cursed with feeling guilt more than others. And there's four reasons in particular why that might be. Firstly, if you're a people pleaser, if you have high empathy or a childhood guilt wound,
你知道，举个例子，你可以为自己的体重或性取向感到羞耻。这并不意味着它是错的，也不意味着你活该有这种感觉，而内疚更多的是源于一种认知：即你所做的事情违背了社会如何选择对待他人的某种更深层的原则，即使事实并非如此。我想在这里转向长期内疚，因为这实际上才是本集的重点。而我刚才已经扯得太远了。但我们当中确实有一些人似乎比别人更容易感到内疚，对此有四个具体的原因。首先，如果你是个讨好型人格，如果你拥有高度的同理心或童年内疚创伤，
perfectionism, and then of course, guilt that is triggered by a mistake or a behavior that is going to lead to excessive rumination and playing back that moment. Those are the four main reasons why there are certain people out there who feel guilt more than others. Let's start by examining people pleasing here. People pleasing is perhaps the most understandable factor to me because I think when we have that high level of sensitivity to others' needs, we also have the highest level of sensitivity to someone's disappointment with us as well. People pleasing for a bit of a refresher. It occurs when we really prioritise other people people's feelings, happiness and needs over honouring our own needs. The thing is, people pleasing
完美主义，然后当然还有由错误或某种行为触发的内疚，这种内疚会导致过度的反刍思维并不断回放那个时刻。这就是为什么某些人比其他人更容易感到内疚的四个主要原因。让我们首先来审视讨好型人格（people pleasing）。对我而言，讨好型人格或许是最容易理解的因素，因为我认为当我们对别人的需求有着高度的敏感性时，我们对别人对我们的失望同样也拥有最高级别的敏感性。温故知新一下，讨好型人格。它发生在当我们真正优先考虑别人的感受、快乐和需求，而不是尊重我们自己的需求时。问题在于，讨好型人格
behaviours and tendencies from the outside look really good, right? It looks like you're really polite, like you're really agreeable and generous and nice. Society really approves of these behaviours. It doesn't necessarily mean that people pleasing is healthy though, because every time we willingly do something for others because we think it's going to make them happier, because we think it's going to make them like us more. And it comes at an inconvenience to us. We are abandoning ourselves. We are embodying our false self for the benefit of someone else. So there is this book called Real Talk and it was written by this amazing therapist called Tasha Bailey. She was actually on the podcast last month.
的行为和倾向从外表上看非常好，对吧？它看起来像是你非常有礼貌、随和、慷慨而且友善。社会非常赞同这些行为。但这并不一定意味着讨好型人格是健康的，因为每一次我们为了让别人更高兴、为了让别人更喜欢我们而心甘情愿地为他们做某事，并且这给我们带来了不便时，我们其实是在抛弃自我。为了别人的利益，我们在具象化我们虚假的自我。所以有一本书叫《真实对话》（Real Talk），是由一位名叫塔莎·贝利（Tasha Bailey）的出色治疗师写的。她上个月刚来过这个播客节目。
And she explains this really well. She explains how people-pleasing tendencies normally emerge from what we call the fawn response. We've talked about this before, but essentially, psychologists used to believe that when we encounter a threat in our environment, we could either fight back or run away. That is our fight or flight response. But recently, they've noticed a new type of response, too, in fact. The first one was freeze, we just don't do anything. And the second one was fawn.
她把这一点解释得非常好。她解释了讨好倾向通常是如何从我们所谓的“应激顺从反应”（fawn response）中产生的。我们以前讨论过这个，但本质上，心理学家过去认为，当我们在环境中遇到威胁时，我们要么反击，要么逃跑。这就是我们的“战斗或逃跑反应”（fight or flight response）。但最近，他们注意到了另外两种类型的反应，实际上是两种。第一种是僵住（freeze），我们什么都不做。第二种是顺从（fawn）。
And the fawn response occurs when we kind of essentially roll over. Like there's a predator there, it's going to eat us. And we like wag our tail and we're really nice and we appease the threat. If someone is like angry at you for like stealing their parking spot at like a Kmart or whatever, instead of like trying to fight them about it or running away or ignoring them, if you are activating your phone response, you apologize profusely. You smile, you try and be complimentary as a way to minimize the threat. People pleasing is born from this response. And we often learn it from being in environments where we realized that it was better for us if other people
而应激顺从反应发生在我们基本上选择逆来顺受的时候。就像那里有一只捕食者，它要吃掉我们。而我们摇尾巴，表现得非常友善，以此来安抚这个威胁。如果有人因为你抢了他们在Kmart或者其他地方的停车位而对你感到愤怒，如果你激活的不是和他们争吵、逃跑或忽视他们的反应，而是你的顺从反应，你会疯狂地道歉。你会微笑，试着说奉承的话，以此来将威胁降到最低。讨好型人格就诞生于这种反应。我们通常是在这样的环境中学会这一点的：我们意识到，如果别人
didn't see us as a threat or we made ourselves smaller to avoid their anger. When we have lived like this for a really long time, we may not even realize that this is what we're doing. It becomes involuntary. It becomes automatic. It's second nature. And the problem with being a people pleaser is that at some stage, you are going to need to set a boundary or say no. You might have to disappoint someone. You're going to have to put yourself first or maybe even accept that people are taking advantage of your kindness or your generosity. When we do this, it feels so unnatural to set those boundaries. And that is how we begin to experience guilt, especially when it comes to our relationships. We have learnt to feel guilty when we don't prioritize other people's feelings
不把我们视为威胁，或者我们把自己变得渺小以避免他们的愤怒，这对我们来说会更好。当我们以这种方式生活了很长一段时间后，我们甚至可能意识不到这就是我们在做的事。它变得不由自主。它变得自动化。它成了我们的第二本能。而作为讨好型人格的问题在于，在某个阶段，你需要设定界限或说“不”。你可能不得不让某个人失望。你将不得不把你自己放在第一位，或者甚至接受有些人正在利用你的善良或慷慨的事实。当我们这样做时，设定这些界限感觉太不自然了。而这就是我们开始体验到内疚的方式，尤其是在我们的关系中。我们已经学会了每当没有把别人的感受置于
above our own, when we roll over for them, when we kind of take their feelings into account. And these people around us who are used to us constantly being this very passive, pleasing agent, they're kind of shocked when we no longer give them that permission. And that shock perhaps even that anger, that frustration that comes from them, that's going to make us feel equally guilty and perhaps selfish because once again, we are highly attuned to their emotions and we feel responsible for them. But the thing is, is that you cannot live your life for others because you will lose yourself. And you'll soon realize that a lot of people who you've constantly been trying to accommodate, who you've constantly been trying to, you know, win their favor, be kind to
我们自己之上时、当我们对他们逆来顺受时、当我们把他们的感受考虑进去时，就会感到内疚。而我们身边这些习惯了我们总是扮演这种非常被动的、讨好角色的那些人，当我们不再赋予他们这种特权时，他们会感到震惊。这种震惊，或许甚至是来自于他们的愤怒和挫败感，会让我们感到同样的内疚，或许还会觉得自己很自私，因为我们再次对他们的情绪高度敏感，并为此感到责任。但事实是，你不能为别人过日子，因为你会迷失自我。而且你很快就会发现，许多你一直试图迎合的人、你一直试图去赢得他们的青睐、对他们好、
them, make them like you, as soon as you put up that boundary and say, no, I'm sorry, like, I don't want to do that, they suddenly disappear from your life. And it's a really big wake-up call. When we think about where this originates this chronic guilt, yes, it comes from people-pleasing, but it also comes from a lot of the childhood wounds that we carry from when we were children. We know that how we were raised, the experiences we had in our very early, formative years, they are incredibly influential to the adult that we become. So the childhood guilt wound is really important to understand here. And it typically emerges in children who were raised by parents or caregivers
让他们喜欢你的人，一旦你树立起界限并说“不，我很抱歉，我不想那样做”，他们就会突然从你的生活中消失。这是一个非常大的警钟。当我们思考这种长期内疚的起源时，是的，它源于讨好型人格，但它也源于我们作为孩子时所承载的许多童年创伤。我们知道，我们的抚养方式、我们在非常早期的成长岁月中经历的事情，对我们成年后成为什么样的人有着难以置信的影响。因此，理解这里的童年内疚创伤非常重要。它通常出现在由那些
who projected a lot of their frustrations or anger onto their children. They got upset at them really quickly, they had emotional outbursts, or they used guilt as a form of discipline. So they induced feelings of wrongdoing as a way of scolding their children, as a way of, you know, making them feel ashamed of their behavior and bringing them back into line. So this may have included times or situations when you had no reason to feel guilt at all, when it was just an accident, like you forgot your school bag or you spilled something or you lost a form, mistakes that children make.
将大量挫折感或愤怒投射到孩子身上的父母或看护人抚养长大的孩子身上。他们对孩子很快失去耐心，情绪爆发，或者把内疚作为一种纪律惩罚手段。因此，他们通过诱发做错事的感觉来训斥孩子，以此让他们对自己的行为感到羞耻并重新听话。这可能包括那些你根本没有理由感到内疚的时间或情况，当它只是一场意外时，比如你忘带了书包、打翻了东西或者弄丢了表格，这些都是小孩子常犯的错误。
but because you are made to feel guilty for something minor, this leaves an impact, this leaves an emotional wound, an emotional scar. These kinds of children often grow up to be really, really sensitive to the needs and emotions of others because they've had to adopt that role with their parents. They evolve into empaths. They go to extra lengths to help anybody else, even when it's unfeasible, and they also criticize themselves for the smallest mistakes. A failure to make someone else happy leaves them feeling guilty because it is replicating why and how they were made to feel guilty as a child. So we grow into adults who are still trying day after day to meet unreasonable expectations. We are still those children who want to make everybody happy. And that is an impossible task
但因为你为了一点小事被弄得感到内疚，这留下了影响，留下了一个情感创伤、情感伤疤。这样的孩子长大后往往会对其他人的需求和情绪变得非常、非常敏感，因为他们不得不与父母一起扮演那个角色。他们进化成了共情者。他们会竭尽全力去帮助任何人，哪怕这是不可行的，而且他们还会为最小的错误而严厉批评自己。未能让其他人开心会让他们感到内疚，因为这复制了他们小时候被弄得感到内疚的原因和方式。所以我们长大了，成天还在试图达到不合理的期望。我们依然是那些想要让每个人都开心的孩子。而那是一项不可能完成的任务，
and that is what leaves us feeling guilty a lot of times when we don't even need to. The final big contributor is perfectionism, our age-old arch nemesis. We talk about this on the show all the time because it is, it really is the string that ties so much together. So there's kind of two types of perfectionists, but it's particularly self-orientated perfectionists in these moments that are impacted by this. So self-orientated perfectionists, they are the people amongst us who set high standards for themselves that are unattainable and they're particularly concerned with doing things the right way. I think perfectionism differs from the other contributing factors here because it has less to do with the social side of guilt and more to do with the feeling of guilt that you aren't living up to
也就是这一点让我们很多时候在根本不需要内疚时感到了内疚。最后一大诱因是完美主义，我们老掉牙的死对头。我们在节目中一直在谈论这个，因为它确实是把这么多东西串联在一起的线索。所以完美主义大概有两种类型，但在这类时刻受到这种影响的，尤其是自我导向型完美主义者。所以自我导向型完美主义者，他们是我们当中那些为自己设定了高得无法企及的标准、并且特别关注以正确方式做事的人。我认为完美主义与这里的其他诱因不同，因为它与内疚的社会侧面关系较小，而更多地与这样一种内疚感有关：你觉得你没有达到
expectations, that you aren't working hard enough, that you aren't deserving of what you've achieved. This is a generation of perfectionists. We are seeing studies consistently that are showing a very linear and increasing rates of perfectionists in this generation. Possibly because of what they suggest is an increasing emphasis on competitive individualism. Now that is an emphasis on being successful and focused on your own goals rather than the goals of the group. So that basically means that you feel a lot of pressure and expectation to be the best to prove yourself deserving of opportunities, prove yourself deserving of achievement. When we can't do that, our social instinct is to feel guilt. As this, we've, you know, done something wrong because we're not fitting into that
期望，你觉得你工作不够努力，你觉得你配不上你所取得的成就。这是一个充满完美主义者的世代。我们看到的研究始终显示出这一代人中完美主义者的比例呈线性且不断上升的趋势。这可能是因为他们所说的，对竞争性个人主义（competitive individualism）的日益强调。现在，这种强调重点在于成功，并专注于你自己的目标，而不是团队的目标。所以这基本上意味着你感到了巨大的压力和期望，要成为最棒的人，要证明自己配得上机遇，证明自己配得上成就。当我们做不到这一点时，我们的社会本能就是感到内疚。仿佛我们，你知道的，做错了什么，因为我们没有融入那种
competitive, constantly succeeding, progressing mold, especially in the cases where our parents have worked really hard for our opportunities, or in the cases where you are kind of the golden child, the one who everyone is putting expectations on. We're also facing a lot of worsening social and economic conditions compared to our parents. And that paired with an increasing emphasis on being carefree and having options and having different paths keeps us in a place of feeling really stuck and feeling like there is something that we should do, but something that we would like to do. These pathways in live, right, there's so many different ones, go to uni, don't go to uni, travel the world, don't travel the world, get a corporate job, get an internship,
竞争性的、不断成功、不断进步的模范中，特别是在我们的父母为我们的机遇付出了巨大努力的情况下，或者在你是那种每个人都把期望寄托其上的“金色小孩”（golden child）的情况下。与我们的父母相比，我们还面临着不断恶化的社会和经济状况。再加上对无忧无虑、拥有多种选择和不同人生道路的日益强调，这使我们陷入了一种深深的卡顿感中，总觉得有些事是我们应该做的，但又有另一些事是我们想做的。人生中的这些道路，对吧，有那么多不同的选择。去上大学，不上大学；环游世界，不环游世界；找一份公司的工作，找一份实习，
go and be a creative. There are so many. There are so many. pathways that feel mutually exclusive. So choosing a pathway is difficult. It brings up a lot of cognitive dissonance and with that comes either this pressure of not living up to your potential or this pressure of not making yourself happy. And with that guilt of not living up to your potential or guilt for wasting your years, wasting your young years, wasting what you know would make you feel fulfilled. Like we spoke about before, it's that sense that you are doing something wrong that leads to feelings of guilt and it's not always a social feeling. Sometimes it's that you're not, you're doing something wrong in comparison to what you feel like
去当个创意工作者。有太多了。有这么多的道路。它们感觉是互不相容的。所以选择一条道路是很困难的。它会带来大量的认知失调，并随之产生两种压力：要么是未能达到潜力的压力，要么是无法让自己快乐的压力。随之而来的便是未能达到潜力的内疚，或者觉得自己浪费了光阴、浪费了年轻岁月、浪费了那些你知道能让自己感到充实的事情的内疚。正如我们之前所讨论的，那种觉得自己正在做错事的赶脚会导致内疚感，而且这并不总是一种社会层面的感觉。有时是因为与你觉得你“应该”做的事情相比，你觉得自己做错了事。
you should be doing. The thing that we need to remember is that your only duty at the end of the day is to live a life that you find fulfilling, that you find deeply inspiring and nourishing and joy inducing even if it's not what others expect from you. You don't need to feel guilty for taking your time, for taking it slow, for changing your mind at any point. So all of these explanations focus on that guilt complex, guilt with no apparent reason or justified explanation. But we also have reactive guilt, which is when we have done, you know, we've done something wrong, we've hurt somebody, we've acted against what we knew was right, our moral code, and we are left with a deep sense of regret and remorse and maybe even struggling to see ourselves beyond our actions. We are this one bad thing that we did and nothing will ever change that. that is kind of the cognitive distortion that we buy into.
我们要记住的是，归根结底，你唯一的责任就是过一种你觉得充实、深具启发性、充满滋养和快乐的生活，哪怕这并非别人对你的期望。你不需要为花时间、为放慢脚步、为在任何时刻改变主意而感到内疚。因此，所有这些解释都集中在内疚情结上，即没有明显原因或正当解释的内疚。但我们也有反应性内疚，也就是当我们做了，你知道的，我们做错了事，我们伤害了某人，我们的行为违背了我们明知是正确的道德准则，从而给我们留下了一种深深的遗憾和悔恨感，甚至可能让我们难以从自己的行为中看到真实的自我。我们认为自己就是那个做过一件坏事的坏人，没有什么能改变这一点。这就是我们笃信的那种认知扭曲。
We believe that just because we acted against our better judgment once, that makes us an evil person. I think if you grew up in a very religious family or even had some religious education, this is going to influence you more than you know. Additionally, those broader themes of good and bad and being a good person are everywhere in society. and we often feel like our worst moments are therefore what defines us and that they kind of outshine the a million other things that we do, the millions of other moments of empathy and kindness. I think guilt in this moment is hard because you know that you've done something wrong
我们相信，仅仅因为我们有一次违背了更好的判断，就让我们变成了一个恶人。我想如果你在一个非常宗教氛围的家庭中长大，或者甚至接受过一些宗教教育，这会对你产生超乎你想象的影响。此外，关于善恶以及做一个好人的那些更广泛的主题在社会中随处可见，而我们常常觉得我们最糟糕的时刻因此定义了我们，并且它们似乎盖过了其他数百万件我们所做的事情、数百万个表现出同理心和善良的时刻。我认为内疚在这一刻是艰难的，因为你知道自己做错了事，
and it's not meant to become maladaptive, it's not meant to keep you in a dark place of self-pity and regret. It is meant to serve as a teachable moment, a moment for accountability. this wouldn't feel as bad if you weren't actually a good person. If you were a bad person who lacks empathy and kindness and sincerity, you wouldn't be feeling this way. So your guilt is in itself a reminder of the fact that you are a good person who has done a bad thing.
它不应该变成一种适应不良的东西，它不该让你停留在自怜和后悔的黑暗地方。它应该成为一个可以从中学习的时刻，一个承担责任的时刻。如果你不是一个真正的好人，这感觉就不会这么糟糕。如果你是一个缺乏同理心、善良和真诚的坏人，你就不会有这种感觉。所以你的内疚本身就是在提醒你一个事实：你其实是一个做了一件坏事的好人。
Whether you've heard a friend, you've said something that you shouldn't have, you've let someone down, you've cheated, you've let yourself down. The easiest way to ensure that you don't learn from this experience is to avoid, this emotion. So what I want to talk about next is how to integrate it, how to overcome our chronic feelings of guilt, our guilt complex, how to stop making guilt a staple of who you are. All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness,
无论你伤害了一个朋友、说了一些不该说的话、让某人失望了、欺骗了别人，还是让你自己失望了。确保你无法从中吸取教训的最简单方法，就是逃避这种情感。所以接下来我想讨论的是，如何去整合它，如何克服我们长期的内疚感、我们的内疚情结，以及如何停止让内疚成为你性格中的核心要素。所有这些以及更多内容，将在短暂停留后继续。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理坚韧、健身的科学
and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
并在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些充斥在健康产业中不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听 2%。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他你获取播客的平台上搜索 TWO%，即可收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会剖析事件，复盘发生的一切，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都能聊一整天快克，但只是让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目，所以我开始看出它们之间有某种内在联系了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，和我卡尔·盖恩斯一起，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.
2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你串改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我串改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we've talked about two different guilt experiences here, reactive guilt. actually doing something that has hurt someone or damaged some part of your life, and then
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以我们在这里讨论了两种不同的内疚体验，反应性内疚。实际上做了伤害某人或损害你生活某一部分的事情，然后
the guilt complex, chronic feelings of guilt that have no specific or real source. So I really want to focus on the second experience here. I think overcoming reactive guilt is a much more simple equation. Maybe that is a bit diluted of me, but I do believe it is more based on making amends, apologising sincerely, making a commitment to grow and learn from your mistakes. We have a equation, a solution for dealing with reactive guilt. But the issue with the guilt complex is that the source of it is a lot more unidentifiable. It's very mental. We're searching for things to feel guilty about before they even emerge rather than feeling guilt naturally in response to some experience or event. we've explained why that is because obviously we're instinctual people pleases we carry a childhood guilt wound
内疚情结，即没有具体或真实来源的慢性内疚感。所以我真的很想把重点放在第二种体验上。我认为克服反应性内疚是一个更简单的公式。也许我这么说有点过于简化了，但我确实相信它更多地基于弥补、真诚道歉、承诺从错误中成长和学习。我们有一个处理反应性内疚的公式和解决方案。但内疚情结的问题在于，它的根源更加难以识别。它是非常心理层面的。我们在事情甚至还没发生之前就开始寻找感到内疚的理由，而不是为了回应某些经历或事件而自然地感到内疚。我们已经解释了为什么会这样，因为显然我们是本能的取悦者，我们带着童年的内疚伤口
we're perfectionists maybe we also struggle with anxiety or obsessive and intrusive thoughts i know it all too well guilt for resting guilt for not resting guilt for all of those things it's very never-ending but here are some ways that i've challenged that recently and a lot of it is based in cognitive behavioral theory so that is also known as CBT for short it's this idea that when we deliberately change our attitude or our perception of our emotions, we also change our behavioral tendencies that are attached to them. We stop searching, we stop ruminating. And one way I did this was by telling myself that guilt was boring. I've spoken about this when it comes to fear, but it's boring to be thinking about the same emotion repetitively day in and day out.
我们是完美主义者，也许我们还在与焦虑或强迫性、侵入性思维作斗争。我对此太了解了。为休息而内疚，为不休息而内疚，为所有这些事情而内疚。这似乎没完没了，但这里有一些我最近用来挑战这种状态的方法，其中很多都基于认知行为理论，也就是简称的 CBT。这就是这个理念：当我们刻意改变对情绪的态度或看法时，我们也改变了与之相连的行为倾向。我们停止寻找，我们停止反刍。我做到这一点的方法之一是告诉自己内疚很无聊。当谈到恐惧时我也说过这个，但日复一日地反复思考同一种情绪真的很无聊。
guilt is a waste of my energy, especially when it comes to a guilt complex. It's counterproductive. When I think of my guilt as boring rather than as useful, it becomes a lot easier to discredit. It's so easy to reinforce this belief as well. When you think your friend is mad at you for needing to spend a day by yourself for cancelling plans, when you're anxious that you're disappointing someone, that you're falling behind, that you're failing yourself, literally say to yourself, speak these words in your mind. This is boring. This guilt I'm feeling is boring.
内疚是对我精力的浪费，特别是当涉及到内疚情结时。这是适得其反的。当我把内疚视为无聊而不是有用时，它就变得更容易被打破。强化这种信念也非常容易。当你认为朋友因为你需要花一天时间独处、因为你取消了计划而生你的气时，当你担心自己让别人失望、自己正在落后、自己正在辜负自己时，字面意思上对自己说，在心中默念这些话。这很无聊。我感到的这种内疚很无聊。
I am bored by this emotion. I'm going to think about something else now. You stop treating the emotion as a fact. You stop putting it on a pedestal. You stop treating it like a truth about yourself rather than as just a feeling. And you're choosing not to engage. with it. Also, it's really important to name your guilt. Examine the source and whether it should be believed. Some good prompts are like, straight off the bat, what is it that I actually feel guilty about right now?
我对这种情绪感到厌倦。我现在要去想别的事情了。你不再把这种情绪当作事实来对待。你不再把它高高捧起。你不再把它当作关于你自己的真理，而仅仅把它当作一种感觉。你选择不去理会它。此外，给你的内疚命名也非常重要。检查它的根源以及它是否值得相信。一些好的提示就像，直截了当，我现在真正感到内疚的是什么？
Has someone actually been hurt by my actions? Have I been hurt by my actions? Or is this just a feeling that I have? Is it me trying to like, is it my hypervigilance? Is it me trying to identify something before it's occurred? is that justified? Can I actually identify a specific choice, action, behavior that I could have changed to be feeling differently right now? Remember that you are just one person right now, you know, and this feeling of guilt is often coming from a place of caring more about the feelings of others than caring about your own feelings, especially that unspecified guilt. You cannot do it all. You cannot make everybody happy. And a sad reality, I think, for a lot of us who are people pleases is that sometimes people are going to just be disappointed in you. You might hurt their feelings. You might
是否有人因为我的行为而真正受到伤害？我是否因为自己的行为而受到伤害？还是这只是我的一种感觉？这是我在试图，这是我的过度警觉吗？是我在试图在事情发生之前找出点什么吗？这有正当理由吗？我能否真正确定某个我可以改变的选择、行动或行为，从而让我现在的感觉有所不同？记住，你现在只是一个人，你知道，这种内疚感往往来自于比起关心自己的感受，你更关心他人感受的心态，尤其是那种说不清道不明的内疚。你无法做到面面俱到。你无法让所有人都开心。对于我们这些讨好型人格的人来说，一个悲伤的现实是，有时人们就是会对你感到失望。你可能会伤害他们的感情。你甚至可能
annoy them, even without realizing it. But unless they say something to you, unless they, that you know that you've screwed up, unless they are explicit, it is none of your business, what they choose to think privately and how they choose to manage their emotions. You are not a mind, reader and I think even if you were you would find that a lot of people aren't thinking about it that deeply. No one is mad at you. No one is holding a grudge. You've not let them down. And if you believe that you have, challenge that belief or ask them. Just be vulnerable and ask them. Say, hey, I kind of need some reassurance right now. I'm feeling like guilty for this thing. Can you tell me whether that is like a rational feeling to be had? And I would say 99% of the
惹恼他们，甚至自己都没有意识到。但除非他们对你说了什么，除非他们，你知道你搞砸了，除非他们明确表态，否则他们私下里选择怎么想、如何管理自己的情绪，这都与你无关。你不是读心术士，而且我认为即使你是，你也会发现很多人根本没有想得那么深。没有人对你生气。没有人对你怀恨在心。你没有让她们失望。如果你认为自己做到了，去挑战这种信念，或者去问问他们。勇敢一点，去问问他们。说，嘿，我现在有点需要一些安慰。我为这件事感到内疚。你能告诉我这算是一种理性的感觉吗？我会说 99% 的
the time they'll be honest with you. They'll understand because I think this is a universal experience. They'll understand that you are coming from a place of genuinely caring about them and wanting to do them right. Also, if you are struggling with chronic underlying guilt for whatever it may be, it might actually be a symptom of actually just being quite burnt out and overwhelmed. When we are burnt out, when we are at like the end of our tether, you don't have the same cognitive defenses to keep the negative beliefs and feelings at bay. That is where rest is so important, but it's often neglected because a lot of us, particularly perfectionists, feel guilty for resting. We feel lazy. We feel like we haven't worked hard enough. And so rest often makes us feel more guilty.
时间他们都会对你诚实。他们会理解，因为我认为这是一种普遍的体验。他们会理解你是出于真心关心他们并希望做得对。此外，如果你正在为某种原因而挣扎于长期的潜在内疚感之中，它实际上可能只是精疲力竭和不堪重负的一个症状。当我们精疲力竭，当我们处于山穷水尽的边缘时，你没有相同的认知防御来把负面的信念和感觉挡在门外。这就是休息如此重要的原因，但它经常被忽视，因为我们很多人，尤其是完美主义者，会为休息感到内疚。我们觉得自己很懒。我们觉得自己工作不够努力。因此休息往往让我们感到更内疚。
It's this cycle. But it is not true that you need to earn rest. Rest is so important for your body, but also for your mind. And it means prioritizing mental, physical, emotional, and social timeout and social breaks. Give yourself a day to just be with yourself, to do what you want, to not be responsible to any other people, to any work commitments, to any, you know, study commitments, whether that is laying in bed all day, taking yourself for a hike, just not seeing other people. This really has a lot of benefits, too, in particular. A, it allows us to deprioritize other people's needs and concentrate on our own, so really reducing our sense that we need to make them happy and feeling guilty when we can't.
这是一个循环。但你不需要通过努力来赢得休息，这种说法是不正确的。休息对你的身体至关重要，对你的心灵同样重要。这意味着优先安排精神、身体、情感和社交上的暂停与休息。给自己一天时间，只是和自己呆在一起，做你想做的事，不对任何其他人负责，不对任何工作承诺负责，不对任何你知道的学习承诺负责，不管是整天躺在床上，还是去徒步旅行，就是不去看其他人。这其实有很多好处，特别是。A，它使我们能够将其他人的需求降级，专注于我们自己的需求，从而真正减少那种我们需要让他们开心、做不到时就会感到内疚的心态；
And B, it ensures that you are filling up your cup when it is getting depleted and that you can handle bad thoughts or hard situations because you are mentally sharp and healthy. Finally, we have to talk about self-forgiveness and radical self-compassion here. sometimes we become stuck in our negative beliefs because we feel like we deserve to be there. We use guilt as a way to self-punish, as a way to almost feel like we're repenting and making up for some past mistake by making ourselves feel bad. We have seen studies and research about this a lot more recently, and there was one in particular that showed that when you magnify your mistake, or possible faults or where your guilt is coming from when you magnify the things that you
以及B，它能确保当你的杯子快要空时，你能将它填满，并且由于你头脑敏锐、身体健康，你能够应对糟糕的想法或艰难的局势。最后，我们必须在这里谈谈自我原谅和彻底的自我同情。有时我们会陷入负面的信念中无法自拔，因为我们觉得自己罪有应得。我们把内疚当作一种自我惩罚的方式，一种几乎像是为了通过让自己感觉糟糕来进行忏悔和弥补过去错误的方式。我们最近看到了更多关于这方面的研究，其中有一个特别的研究表明，当你放大你的错误、
believe you've done wrong and the emotions that come with that it is so self-destructive but it also is a form of self-punishment you know you probably feel like you deserve to feel this way that it's going to make you a better person to keep yourself in this state for a bit longer to keep yourself in pain to justify your actions but really what it's doing is actually keeping you operating from a place of intense sensitivity and needing to adhere to doing everything right. More often than not, the belief that you are bad actually contributes to more bad behavior because it is a self-fulfilling prophecy. There is this incredible book called The Willpower Instinct, and it talks about this so succinct.
可能存在的缺点或内疚的来源时，当你放大那些你认为自己做错了的事情以及随之而来的情绪时，这是极具毁灭性的，但它也是一种自我惩罚的形式（你知道，你可能觉得自己罪有应得，觉得自己保持这种状态久一点、让自己处于痛苦中以证明自己的行为是合理的，会让自己成为一个更好的人），但实际上它所做的一切，是让你继续从一种高度敏感和需要坚持把每件事都做对的心态中运作。通常情况下，认为自己很糟糕的信念实际上会导致更多糟糕的行为，因为它是一个自我实现的预言。有一本极其出色的书叫《意志力本是天性》（The Willpower Instinct），里面非常精辟地谈到了这一点。
It is forgiveness, not guilt, that makes you a better person. and there's been research into this, a study in 2017, found that taking a self-compassionate point of view on personal failure, on hurting other people and on upsetting other people, it actually means that you are more likely to grow from that experience. You become more willing to receive feedback, advice from others, you're more likely to learn and take responsibility. That is something really important to think about in those moments where your guilt is very present. You can choose to stay there. That is totally your choice. You can choose to feel guilty because
是原谅，而不是内疚，才能让你成为一个更好的人。并且这方面也有过相关研究，2017年的一项研究发现，对个人失败、伤害他人以及惹恼他人采取自我同情的视角，实际上意味着你更有可能从那段经历中成长。你变得更愿意接受反馈、他人的建议，你更有可能去学习并承担责任。在内疚感非常强烈的那一刻，这是非常重要的一点。你可以选择留在那里。这完全是你的选择。你可以选择感到内疚，因为
it feels good to feel bad. Or you can choose to practice radical self-compassion and just show yourself so much forgiveness and love for the mistakes you knew you shouldn't have made, but you also didn't know any better at the time. Think about what you were feeling guilty about. Whatever it is, even if it's small, if that was your best friend or your sister or your partner or your mom and the roles were reversed, would you forgive them? The answer is that you probably would. You would forgive them. So what is holding you back from forgiving yourself? Why are you personally undeserving of self-forgiveness? We so often treat others better than we treat ourselves, we are more likely to show them love and compassion. But when we reverse the roles,
感觉糟糕感觉很好。或者你可以选择实践彻底的自我同情，为你明知不该犯但当时又无能为力的错误，向自己展现出极大的原谅与爱。想想你在为什么感到内疚。无论是什么，哪怕是很小的错误，如果那是你最好的朋友、你的妹妹、你的伴侣或你的妈妈，而你们角色互换了，你会原谅他们吗？答案是你很可能会。你会原谅他们。那么是什么阻止了你原谅自己呢？为什么你个人就不配得到自我原谅？我们经常这样，对待别人比对待自己更好，我们更有可能向他们展示爱与同情。但当我们角色互换时，
we have a better perspective on what we're really feeling, whether we are really deserving to live this way. And I think when we examine whether we would put someone we love through the emotional experience we're having, the answer is no. You're a good person. You're a kind person. You wouldn't be feeling guilt otherwise. So please remember, save some of that compassion that you always have for others, some of that forgiveness that you always have for others for yourself, not just for those around you.
我们对自己的真实感受有了更好的视角，看看我们是否真的配得上以这种方式生活。我想当我们审视自己是否会让深爱的人经历我们正在承受的情感折磨时，答案是否定的。你是个好人。你是个善良的人。否则你不会感到内疚。所以请记住，把那些你总是给予别人的同情，把那些你总是给予别人的原谅，也留一部分给自己，不仅仅是给周围的人。
I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. If you are someone who is experiencing chronic guilt, I hope this informed you, inspired you, enlightened you, whatever you were looking to get out of this episode, I really hope that you've received it. You are not alone in this feeling. I say that at the end of almost every episode because when we do start to break down the psychology
我真心希望你喜欢这一集。如果你是一个正在经历慢性内疚的人，我希望这能给你带来启发、灵感、启迪，无论你想从这一集中得到什么，我都真心希望你得到了。在这种感觉中，你并不孤单。我在几乎每一集的结尾都会这么说，因为当我们开始剖析这些情绪体验的心理学时，
of some of these emotional experiences, you begin to realize how universal they are, especially in our 20s. So if you are someone who has experienced chronic guilt, guilt at disappointing others, guilt it, not living up to your expectations. Yeah, I just hope this helped. And you can always message me at that psychology podcast to share your thoughts, feelings, questions about this episode.
你会开始意识到它们是多么具有普遍性，尤其是在我们的二十多岁时。所以，如果你是一个经历过慢性内疚、因让别人失望而内疚、因未能达到期望而内疚的人。是的，我只希望这能有所帮助。你随时可以在那个心理学播客给我发信息，分享你对这一集的想法、感受和问题。
If you enjoyed it or if you think there is someone else who might need to hear this, please feel free to send them a link and share on the love. Also, leave a five-star review wherever you are listening right now, Apple Podcast, Spotify. It helps the show to grow and reach new people. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
如果你喜欢它，或者你认为有其他人可能需要听听这个，请随时把链接发给他们，把爱传递出去。另外，无论你在哪里收听，Apple Podcast，Spotify，都请留下五星好评。这有助于节目的成长并接触到更多人。和往常一样，我们下周将带着另一集回归。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人卡尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way
这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。收听《Learn the Hard Way》
on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎，但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
你串改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我串改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blind. alone. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）、迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。只有我。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学，
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听 2%。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 TWO%。当一群女性发现
they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get. away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们约会的竟然是同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想。逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。